Legion is set I'm bring coffin Berlin
it's time to talk they say Ukraine means
Europe but the government prefers to
speak Russian today in search of the
truth Ukraine Belgium's lawmakers want
to give children the right to die
euthanasia for minors creating a major
debate and stop the presses Kenya's
journalists say they're under attack
with lawmakers trying to gag the media
welcome to the show everyone I've
invited three people today to talk argue
and pry apart these headlines on press
freedom under attack in Africa I'm happy
to welcome to the show Mohammed Calif he
is from DW use Africa desk he has
reported on Kenya for years and he says
when it comes to freedom of the press
Mohamed you say Kenya's loss would be
africa's loss good to have you on the
show with us today thank you children it
should have the right to end their lives
when medicine can no longer help them
that is what Jean Jacques de gucht is
trying to make law in Belgium he is the
Member of Parliament to introduce the
child euthanasia bill we're glad to have
you on the show today and thousands of
Ukrainians continue to demand their
government look west to Europe but
Europe doesn't know what to do with them
now that is the conclusion of Andre
portneuf he is a historian from Ukraine
based in Berlin right now Andre good to
have you on the show you say that
European political leaders have no idea
what is going on inside Ukraine well who
knows what's going on hmm i think that
the current situation in Ukraine is
really very difficult to be analyzed
precisely because we have a number of
social and cultural political movements
at the same time but my key point is
that the European Union in any case
needs a serious long-term strategy
towards Ukraine because what's going on
now in
key if and other cities in Ukraine is a
kind of a challenge not just for the
Ukrainians themselves but for the entire
European politics for the future of
Europe if you wish let me pick up on
that is are we looking at an identity
crisis for Ukraine I mean our is is this
decision with Europe to take this this
agreement with EU is it about Ukrainians
deciding whether or not their European
or Russians isn't that the problem here
they're being asked to decide so first
of all let me try to explain that for
those hundreds of thousands of people on
the streets of Kiev or leave the key
problem in my view is not the mats a
signature in this association agreement
with the EU but and would say the
understanding of the direction of
Ukrainian political cultural development
and this direction is supposed to be pro
European quite often those people they
do believe i would say in naive way but
still they believe that Ukraine has a
real possibility real chance to join the
European Union as a full member well let
me ask you know the other gentleman here
isn't Ukraine a member of Europe isn't
Ukraine European I mean chancho you know
you're you're a European is Ukraine also
a rightful member well the question is
whether the Ukrainian political members
and the Russian political will well set
the Ukrainian people to decide for
themselves to who they belong to the
west or to the east and to if they have
the chance to to create their own future
instead of what russia wants them to
create for their future dude do you
think Mohammed or icr ask you to chime
in on this as a journalist are we
getting a correct picture of what's
happening in Ukraine do you feel like
it's being reported properly
actually what I think it that maybe we
are getting one sided picture in this
center so we are singapore's from
televisions from media the demonstration
aqui live in other cities and these are
all pro year I mean pro-european
demonstrations but actually Ukraine is
not only give and those other cities it
is the largest country i think in europe
i think so we may be mistaken and it is
of course mother in today to the west if
you're coming from from from from the
east right but then there are other
people that may be drumming other drums
dancing evidence yeah obviously
obviously they've been doing that
because that's right the deal was not
signed I mean it is a big question where
does Ukraine's future reside Europe or
Russia as it stands right now Kiev is
planning to nestle itself even more
closely into the influential arms of
Moscow the decision to reject a historic
partnership agreement with the European
Union has sent thousands of people into
the streets demanding that the
government changed course and then
resigned Ukraine's Prime Minister says
it looks and feels like a coup in the
works tens of thousands of people have
been holding rallies in the streets of
Kiev and other Ukrainian cities they are
protesting President Viktor Yanukovych
sudden decision not to sign the plant
association agreement with the EU
Yanukovych was originally supposed to
sign the deal at a summit meeting in
Vilnius last week but despite talks with
EU leaders he stuck to his abrupt u-turn
apparently due to pressure from Russia
the situation has at least for now
United Ukraine's pro-western opposition
leaders who are calling for the
government to step down It was as if a
game of poker had been played over
Ukraine and Russia one but Ukraine is
now in turmoil what is the future of
Kiev's relations with the EU and rape
what about the Prime Minister saying
that the people who are on the street
protesting that they are part of a coup
that is being formed I don't know what
should I don't know what to understand
mean but in my view is what but what I
my question is in what kind of state is
a government if it starts talking about
being overthrown when people you know
just go out in protest which is their
right to do exactly exactly this this is
the key point i would say even more
because the terrible events in the night
from Friday to Saturday when we've seen
this very cruel cruel treatment of the
peaceful student protest in the center
of kiev by the McCune police just
because this police official said we
were trying to clean the place you know
to build this new year 3 which sounds
incredible in any sense so the problem
is that of course there is a huge and
interesting question about the
responsibility of the government in the
entire situation because there are also
attempts in Ukraine to present the story
in a way like that it's the government
who is responsible for the dead end in
the negotiations with the EU and now we
should change it and then maybe continue
it is in some way if it as far as I know
where it is the government's
responsibility the government was in
negotiations with the EU for years and
then at the last moment he have said no
exactly I would say there was a very
keyword in the this shot reportage
socialism sudden the way how this
decision was presented to the Ukrainian
people wasn't my view the main reason
for this first rerun protest okay well
it tell us that I mean how back home
what are people being told what happened
to the deal with the e so the official
version is that this deal is postponed
just postponed but everybody understands
that in fact we are facing a situation
when efficient Keef rejects this
agreement and probably will try its best
first to sign something else with
Russian what about what about the the
agreement with Moscow is exactly is that
being reported exactly nobody knows
actually what exactly are we talking
about in case of these Moscow agreements
in Moscow meetings so we are waiting we
are waiting to the government of the
president will officially explain what's
going on in this Russian judge at this
point there hasn't been any explanation
why they probs postponed no they've
explained that the reason is that
economically economically just
economically Ukraine is not prepared now
to sign this stuff and then let's say
less officially some members of the
government said you know we need a lot
of money for the economic risks we are
taking now and the European Union is not
able to give this money to us so we have
no other choice but to restart
negotiations with Russia and to postpone
the negotiation with the EU so it sounds
ridiculous a would say but is anyone in
Ukraine saying what we're looking at
here is a power game that Vladimir Putin
is winning exactly that's a very common
view actually you know it's interesting
because paradoxically or maybe more
chuckling it's a next question the
entire story of ukraine protests is very
much about Russia so it's not just about
the EU and the European aspirations
about Russia
it's about fears fears of Russia's
influences in Ukraine and Russia's
attempts to get Ukraine back we could
discuss how rational these arguments
about many people also the politicians
they sincerely believe it so it's a kind
of reality of you know perception of the
Russian fact I mean it's a reality
exactly that's it you know that that
sounds like it would make a great novel
but maybe it don't you think at the end
of end of the day we're looking at some
political leaders in Ukraine who
understand the language of money and
power more than democracy because at the
end of the day let me ask if you think
this is what happened Vladimir Putin put
more money on the table and that
convinced Kiev okay yes or no we don't
know yet but what we know for sure is
that the Ukrainian political elites they
are corrupted no doubt about it and they
do not understand what European politics
about international politics on the
higher level means and that's the
problem so you see this is holly I don't
think they're I mean do you really think
that they don't understand I mean
they've been in negotiations with
Brussels for years on this agreement
it's not nothing has been presented to
Kiev that's new so so I mean they're not
I mean they're not stupid they know what
they've been doing for the past anyway
stupid but you see if you look at the
way for instance how the Ukrainian
delegation how the Cronin president
behaved in Villa new syndrome dis summit
I would say it's a kind of an
unacceptable way of doing diplomacy and
politics so there is a very deep
political and economic crisis inside
Ukraine inside Ukraine but now it's also
again it's a kind of a big question big
problem for both Russia and the EU how
to deal with this situation in Ukraine
and how to deal would say how to talk to
each other and say how Brussels could
now talk to Moscow about the ongoing
crisis in Ukraine what is the big
question let me
ask everyone what their take is on this
Yanukovych has asked the European
Commission if he can send another
delegation to Brussels he wants to talk
about the agreement with the EU again
the EU has said yes but we're not
renegotiating what's Ukraine up to are
they coming basically and saying match
the money that Putin gave us is is that
what we're looking at my place you can
save now the precious is paramount in
Kiev and of course we cannot ignore the
power of people in Kiev in the in the
country itself we it is only ten years
ago and Rose that orange revolution in
it so it cannot only be the question of
beginning for more money it's also
beginning for staying in power and set
in the face and that's that's why it's
paramount is getting back to what you
say right they don't want another
revolution exact right yes for sure the
primary task which is to preserve the
existing economic and political start of
school and of course it's not an easy
task keeping in mind first the depths of
the economic crisis in the country
second the complicated geopolitical
situation and third of course thousands
of people on the strivers let us pick up
on what's happening on the street right
now do you think these protests are
going to stay peaceful because they're
not getting smaller how they handle it
now exactly right it depends on many
factors you see I do see and I have this
feeling that the leaders of the
Opposition they are trying their best to
keep it peaceful that's important but
the question is okay they are trying
their best but where are the limits of
their would say compressor isn't
particularly go to the other side I mean
when I heard that the Prime Minister had
spoken about a coupe then my first
reaction was that is the green light to
crack down right i mean that's that's
where we're headed aren't we at least it
sounds terrifying i would say it sounds
disturbing very much and that is very as
far as i know
those people who are with span in their
days and nights in Maidan and so on they
are more or less prepared also to this
violent version but of course we all
hope that Ukraine will be able to avoid
it because it's the worst possible
scenario no doubt about it open physical
violence then is very difficult to
predict what could happen to the entire
political entity because you're
absolutely right it's a big country very
close to the European Union so possible
disturb use a shin of this country could
cause a very serious crisis on the right
like like something like like a civil
war you're not talking about something
like that I would say that my big hope
of course is to avoid any any worse so
any city was like that but we should
keep in mind so to say on the onus on
the dangerous possibilities yeah
possibly emerging from the ongoing mass
protests but we have to move on but let
me ask you and Ray you are Ukrainian
maybe you can answer the biggest
question of the day do you feel European
or do you feel more Russian ah ok so
first of all first of all I need I need
I need a quick engine might be running
out of time I feel of course European
but it does not mean that me personally
or many other people in Ukraine have any
what's the anti-russian sentiments not
at all which is my native languages
Russian I write a lot of text in russian
so there is no kind of one would say
deep opposition which is not say
vironment in itself it's a kind of a
normal cultural and political let's see
but you're sitting in Berlin now and
you're not sitting in Moscow that that's
a lot that's true that's why I'm
uncertain all right well listen if
you're watching on keep the discussion
going we'd like to know what you think
what's going to happen in the Ukraine
tell us what you think on Twitter it's
hashtag DW agenda you go there and you
can tell us if you think Ukraine is
heading for peace or for something that
could be violent all right let's move on
there are only
three countries in the world which allow
legal suicide for terminally ill people
and they are all here in Europe Belgium
Luxembourg and the Netherlands now in
the main adults are the only ones
allowed to exercise their so called
euthanasia rights but Belgium could
change that lawmakers there have
introduced legislation that would extend
euthanasia rights to children of any age
should terminally ill children be
allowed to choose to die lawmakers in
Belgium want to extend the country's
already liberal euthanasia law to people
under 18 years of age a draft law passed
in the Senate committees by a large
majority with only the Christian
Democrats opposing it advocates say the
law would provide a legal framework for
doctors to assist inhumanely ending the
lives of minors whose physical suffering
cannot be alleviated but the issue has
prompted an emotional public debate a
vote in parliament on the amended law is
expected in the upcoming weeks Jean Jean
you introduced the legislation do you
think it's going to become law think so
yes we had a very good debate in the
commission for the last six months we
had several hearings with doctors as
well as as lawyers about the law so I
think normally around new year we'll
have the vote in the Senate and then in
goes to the chamber of Representatives
and then normally before the next
election school will have the
legislative act yes why did you decide
to sponsor this legislation because I
think it's very important that people
who suffer that they can make the choice
how to cope with that suffering with
that terminal illness and next to that
it's also very important for the doctors
who are confronted with that question
today
that they have a law frame legislative
frame where they can choose how to
handle that yesterday they are
confronted with that question there is
no law there is no law I mean tell us
what the situation is in Belgium if a
ten-year-old has terminal cancer and
euthanasia is brought up as an option
who decides then is it the parent the
parents have the authority to say yes
first of all it's always the patient who
asked to ask for you tunisia if we're
talking about is also minus it's always
the patient who asks for you tunisia
repeatedly as well as written right but
under the current legislation a minor
under the current it is not possible
right okay that said my question is what
happens when a child is going to die as
for now in the current legislation it's
well we can help him or her to cope with
the suffering to can give extra
medication but there is no law that that
makes it possible that the child asks
for it or the parents intervening
whatever I'm trying to trying to find
out if there is a problem with the with
the current law I mean are there cases
where children have asked to end their
lives and the parents have said no as I
know now no but there are cases where
patients who have terminal illnesses
have asked for you tunisia and where the
ductus actually helped those patients we
had a hearing with it with the doctor
who really thought said well the
legislation doesn't give me the
possibility for now but we have done it
in the in the near past that we
we have helped minus who are confronted
with this is so what happens then with
this new legislation I'm just I'm trying
to imagine there's a ten-year-old in the
hospital dying of cancer and the 10 year
old says that he wants to die he doesn't
want to do the chemo anymore and he
tells the doctor I want to die and the
parents say no that's already possible
you can you can already asked the doctor
to stop your medication that's already
possible but let's not talk about the 10
year old let's talk about the minor who
is capable of asking for you Tunisia who
has the capacities well as a 10 year of
14 year old right well that depends on
the 14 year old it depends on the 10
year old it's that's why we have written
in the in the proposal that there has to
be a psychological analysis if that
patient is truly in the capacity of
making that choice if the patient truly
understands the difference between life
and death and truly understand the
consequences of his choice or her choice
right and in do do you believe that a 10
year old or a 14 year old is completely
cognizant of the finality of death I
believe there is a big difference
between the physical age and the mental
age with a patient who has been
confronted with his or her disease for
months years who has been confronted
with death for several times and who is
indeed in a terminal phase of his
illness I think there is a completely
different way of looking at it and a
completely different mental age as
physically right because they've been
through things that most children don't
have to go through let me ask Mohammed
and Andre what when you hear about this
legislation what goes through your mind
mom if I'm allowed to say for me his car
was crazy expressly for a person to to
to be asking ethnicity for the children
for the child to be asking himself or
herself that I want to die now and then
to be preparing the mechanism for
allowing that request to be sedated
assisted suicide yeah that's right here
you allowing the suicide of the other
chat maybe I can speak only not a niggle
expert or Islamic as you but only is it
parent myself yeah that I will I will
stay with my child to the last minutes
and I won't allow any law that will be
making me allowing my child to ask for
the death and be giving the death on the
plate because of what is suffering it
all suffering is something that we are
passing through in our life it is giving
meaning to the life itself and i think i
think that at that point in you're wrong
i think that the meaning of life is not
you don't know the meaning of life
because of your suffering you know the
meaning of life because of the good
things that yeah yeah joint yeah then
that's right they it is that was meaning
then why you are giving this power of
example to the psychologists to decide
where this child is capable enough of
knowing that the fatality of death and
the the this the bitterness of Tang in
the sufferings why don't you give this
then why don't you give this part of the
psychologist hundred anyone I should
admit I have no it's a easy answer to
this problem but I think that first of
all it already illustrates how important
cultural differences could be also
inside Europe and it would be nice and
important levels are very important in
my view to try to discuss such issues
not just on the memo from some band room
or the Netherlands or catalyst but only
once a European level because it will be
very interesting to move for instance
how the perception
of the program depends on whatever on
the historical tradition of particular
country let's say some people's
religious issues and something like that
way it depends on where you're coming
from exactly where you come in the room
but for instance if you look at this
discussion in a lot of countries it's
indeed a discussion between religious
people okay and the rest that's about
but if you look at this discussion in
Belgium we're over that phase well that
we put that face behind us it's not
about religion religion in this
discussion this is about how do you as a
society cope with that most difficult
part of life and that's the end of life
and I like a lot of religious people in
Belgium who are everywhere for
assistance in the numbers the numbers
support that I mean the majority of the
population in Western Europe is in favor
aye here in Germany it's about
eighty-seven percent I think what makes
people pause here is that you're you're
asking children to take responsibility
for for their lives and to make
decisions it I was asking myself a child
is not allowed to buy cigarettes a child
cannot drive a car but a sick child has
the right to tell the doctor please help
me die I mean yeah but that's an omen
argument if we're talking about life and
death we're not talking about buying a
cigarettes or a bottle of alcohol we're
talking about a terminal ill person who
has been confronted with death who has
been confronted with suffering for
months and years who is in a terminal
face and who is capable of making that
choice we're not talking about a an
innocent child we're talking about the
capable minor who is suffering and who
is in that terminal phase and that's
that's very important missing
face that is a valid point people who
have suffered that cancer for years and
when the doctors say there really is
nothing else we can do for you obviously
those of us who are healthy you know we
can't begin to imagine how they see
things and do you think your legislation
is a recognition of the fact that
terminally ill people are walking down a
different path and they know it well its
first of all it's it's we give the
possibility this is about the
possibility that people have to decide
how they cope with it this doesn't mean
that everybody who is confronted with
the terminal illness has to make that
decision not at all okay i am very for
palliative care yeah but i think it's
very important that people have that
choice and that we as as as lawmakers
make it possible that is why that's why
i'm in politics i'm in politics to give
to the two people the right to choose
their own life path and you're confident
though that this law cannot be abused I
mean your critics say that the current
assisted suicide law has been used to
euthanize people who were depressed who
had anorexia or who had had a sex-change
operation that went wrong terrible thing
but it's not something that you should
die for but they used the law and they
killed themselves are you confident that
this extending this to children that you
can guarantee that the law will not be
abused well first of all we're only
talking about physical illness in mind
having in the discussion about minus
next to that we make laws too well
actually to make sure that there is no
abuse and to make sure that we have a
legislative
part that looks at it if we stop making
laws because the loss can be abused then
we would live in a very strange regime
yeah it's true but when we're talking
about children the stakes are higher
that's what and then that comes said
when you differentiate between between
physical suffering and mental or other
sufferings if you allowing those with
cancer to for supper to decide on their
death and then you don't allow those
with depression other psychological or
mental sufferings which are also
suffering and they are going much deeper
into their life and sometime they are in
many cases in the situation whereby that
is not terrible at all why are you
deciding only on the only physical
sufferings well on minors we took
physical suffering because if we're
talking about psychological suffering we
also for adults we have that possibility
but that's a longer the path that were
making taking for for those patients is
much longer here we're only talking
about the very last part of the terminal
phase that they are in and if we're
talking about- I think we it's very
important that we're talking about- who
are capable of making their choice off
to a terminal physical illness one last
question before you leave I just want to
be clear on this on are you clear that
there is a remedy here if you have a
case where the minor wants to be
euthanized and the parents do not want
that the minor that's that's a horrible
situation to be and but the wall will
allow the minor to be euthanized there
has to be a consent by the parents okay
to be avail clear to ductus of
psychological analysis and the consent
about of the parent of the consent of
the parents always has to be there
always okay good all right well let's
ask you out there watching what do you
think critics say this is a law that
allows us to kill children and obviously
others say that this is a law about
caring for children tell us what you
think
hashtag DW agenda and keep the
conversation going with us all right in
Africa it appears to be a case of shoot
the messenger and it is coming from the
least likely place Kenya is considered a
role model for freedom of the press in
Africa legislation is now working its
way through Parliament that journalists
say is the most repressive media law in
the country's 50-year history now this
did not happen overnight but newspaper
editors say that the government went
into overdrive with the legislation
after the terror attack at the Westgate
shopping mall many journalists openly
criticised how the military handled that
incident and now they say they're being
forced to keep their mouths shut Kenyans
enjoy East Africa's most vibrant media
landscape the nation sits among its
oppressive neighbors as a bastion of
press freedom but a new bill may be
about to change all that parliament has
passed the first stage of the bill which
proposes restrictions on reporting and
huge fines many claim are an attempt to
muzzle the media after September's
Westgate shopping mall attack Kenya's
media alleged soldiers had engaged in
looting news that prompted ministers to
rush the already proposed bill into law
president Uhuru Kenyatta himself an
owner of media assets has sent the bill
back to the drawing board and has
assured the media its freedom will be
respected but critics warn that an
amended version will still curb
journalism in a corner of Africa where
freedom of expression is rare mom let's
just start with the legislative big
questions here one what exactly does
this law do and to why in the world is
the law needed to begin with maybe the
last question fast that's great it's not
it's not needed actually I mean the
critics and media experts in Kenya in
East Africa say that a toll that law is
not needed it it hasn't to be there from
the first beginning but then what does
it say what are the inside Atlee three
things one is that it give the power to
the government-appointed body
2-2 draw and to enforce the code of
conduct for the code of conduct for
journalists so you have a government
body witching what is good conduct for
journalists dust rights okay that
doesn't sound like your press freedom
that's right and then after that it
gives that body the power to find to
pants again say so those jealous which
who they don't respect or who go against
this code of conduct which was
stipulated by this body and then also
which is but in the business way it's
its orders the media to publish or at
least two pro cast forty-five percent of
the local products consider film and any
other film you can sit about to be 45
passes from there for the product from
teeny local programming okay well you
you have stuff like that here in Europe
France is it that exactly that's what
yeah that's but on the okay this body
that will supervise conduct now that is
being point appointed by the Minister of
Information that's right and the
Minister of Information is appointed by
the president so basically the executive
has a final say in whether or not you're
being a good journalist that that's
right and actually what in the first end
up in the First Amendment I mean in the
first bill the law say that this body
should be controlled by the parliaments
but then after President Kenyatta refuse
to the bill he made another amendment in
it and said now know this body should be
controlled by the executive okay so all
right we know all of this smells like a
bad fish but what's going on in Kenya I
mean the when I was reading what
journalists had written i thought well
the country maybe is in shock by what
happened at at westgate and the
automatic reaction is to be too careful
to try to control everything I mean
that's human nature is that what we're
seeing or
are we seeing an undemocratic president
trying to take away liberty Epis Adalia
actually this bill was there was
prepared alia even before the West gets
a test but it was accelerated that
that's right and actually or if you were
following the politics in Kenya they
were having a new constitution in Kenya
and with him they were making some other
power reforms in please in media in
judiciary and area and other other
things this one about this package of
the reforms in the indenter in there
this is not i mean this is this is a
reform in the in the wrong direction the
wrong direction that is it that is it
and so one can sister will consider the
government now is trying to make sure as
much as poor mean as as part as possible
they are getting their hands on the type
of information and also on the direction
of information be given from the country
that is it you know this thing about
trying to control information and
control what we know you know we hear
that now all the time we've heard that
I'm in the West since nine eleven we
hear that what's going on in Ukraine
right now do you feel that the
journalists are going to win this one in
the end Mohammed or is it hopeless the
fight is just difficult it is we can
justify this this fight for from the
Java surprised by then when it comes to
the number of politicians who are for
this bill now you can see they can lose
the fights they will they said yesterday
that mean they say that they go to the
court of law once the bill is being
passed by the government of their
members from the from the apartment from
the the president they'll go to the
court of law so less expect maybe from
the judiciary they will top this load to
be functioning but I'll fight the the
fight is going on now that Jose can know
there is no way for them to him but
there's no even in the way but you you
were telling me earlier that editors
that newspapers have said that they are
going
to sue that's right as soon as this law
is is the past and you're saying that
you don't think the Supreme Court will
strike down the law no it will I will
yeah yeah actually ok I have believed I
mean in many in many states in Kenya
after this new constitution this super
they really have the power within the
same court even the Supreme Court yeah
of course in many instances after the
new constitution in Kenya this Supreme
Court has been acting very Perkins's so
I mean very independently yeah and
checks and balances are working there in
the judiciary's that's not what we're
seeing in Ukraine our example that's
right here right so at least we can see
now from the point of view I mean from
the usual point of view something could
be done there in the court of law have
you seen a change in reporting now since
westgate and since this legislation was
accelerated people are journalists
afraid no they've been David breath till
now and they said note that the first
but the first time the the inspectors
place if Kenya de Mayo told jealousies
you have to come to thee to the office
to be interrogated 40 reported on the
West kid they said no or on it and the
old media industry in Kenya State stood
together or the point until now that
they bring the same as even nothing no
running out telling me just won't find a
question very very briefly there's a lot
more at stake here than just press
freedom in kenya kenya is really a
beacon in that part of africa for
freedom of the press so if the
journalists there lose it's not just
about learning in kenya that's trying to
head is losing it is the lowes the lost
in Africa I mean at least in the region
east africa region they are being
burdened by Tanzania Rwanda Uganda in
Burundi I'm election in dieser from
community the block and these four
countries have been very bad in media
freedom and Kenya was an example for
exactly so now if they lose their fight
in Kenya the fight has been lost also in
other country okay so we have a
pessimistic outlook on Ukraine but we've
got an optimistic outlook on Kenya so
we're going to leave the show today
gentlemen thank
for being on the show with me that's
going to wrap up this edition of agenda
with Brent Gough remember you can
contact me anytime with your thoughts on
the show you can find me on Facebook and
you can tweet me at brent Goff TV email
me as well you see the address on your
screen and if you want to watch the show
again you can go to our website or you
can watch us on youtube I'm Brent Goff
in Berlin join me next time when i set
the agenda
you